yeah this should be like this should be
called like the moments when Lucas like
was around iconic performances dan in
real life is probably my least iconic
character of all it's my uh moving my
dad wrote and directed and I actually
remember auditioning for him in our
living room in the middle of every take
being like ah [ __ ] like I need to go
again I need to go again he was like
you're doing great he was like a whole
thing of a home video camera I I didn't
end up getting cast in that role I got
cast as an as an extra who rides down a
hallway with Healy's and says hi to the
main character and that got cut but I'm
in the last scene of the movie and I
look directly into the camera and it was
the only take that worked so they had to
use him so in that respect it is an
iconic I yes I broke the fourth wall as
an extra hut
my dad did tell me he wanted to name the
character Brad but it never made at IMDb
moonrise kingdom I did a school play and
the casting director saw him unit and
asked me to audition for that movie and
I ended up getting it and I remember Wes
it was what it was that one of the only
jobs that I've been told in person that
I got the rule and he told me in front
of me and my mom he called both of both
of us into the room and it was like I
was the happiest it was like the
happiest day of my life and then the
next day I told everyone in my school
that I was gonna be in a movie
but yeah it's a very specific very
interesting world and there were no
trailers we just we was waited in tents
we weren't allowed to talk to the main
character of Sam and Suzy Jared and Kara
we weren't allowed to talk to them we
tried we tried to get them to come -
fast and furious I think five with us I
was back when they were like in four at
four or five and Wes like put the kibosh
on ax
he was like not happening today he
wanted to create a disconnect between us
which existed between them in the movie
it really felt like we went into the
woods to make it and I don't know when I
look back on it it feels more like I'm
not even sure sure if if it was real in
a way it's one of those sort of fleeting
memories that I can
even entirely grasp it doesn't feel
tangible but also the Redford's based on
robert redford there's some sort of they
based my look off of him and barefoot in
the park me and the other actors we want
we get would get together to watch like
we were like watched all of that
Norton's movies while we're making this
movie and we watched like primal fear
and American History X and Fight Night a
lot of those are really explicit for
like 13 year olds we ended up like
asking him all about it and he was like
I don't think you guys should have seen
those movies but it was yeah it was
really exciting and bill of course is
like was so generous and kind and his
son was on the movie so we got to spend
time with him I remember feeling like so
scared of how fast I was going but after
every take they were like can he go
faster like it looks like he's moving so
slowly but I was like like terrified
[Music]
the grand budapest hotel that that one I
remember I was in Romania at the time
and I got an email from West being like
hey do you want to come on and do a part
on this and I wrote him back the longest
email being like dude thank you so much
this means the world to me this is the
greatest thing ever and he's like yeah
we're so happy to have you it's really
just like a bit part but please like
we're so excited and I was like oh don't
worry you know it's it's it's still so
amazing and anyway I went up and stayed
there for the week for like 30 minutes
of shooting it was like the such a small
chunk but they had a set that was like
this the side of the size of this whole
bowling alley for this one shot with
with like mountains in the background
that we're all like see scenic design
and and snow and it was it was so it was
so beautiful by the way we're inside of
a bowling alley right now this lab got
to work with um Peter Sarsgaard who's
just so generous and amazing to me and
really made me feel comfortable in one
of them in a moment when I was like most
terrified it was like my biggest role at
the time and I was so so scared there's
this one moment on set when I had this
whole monologue at the end of my episode
and I was so nervous about it I'm in the
courtroom it's like my characters moment
and the writer and the director had like
written me about it they were like
prepping me for it like they made it
clear that I had to get it right like it
was like this is the moment and after I
did it I was like okay I think it went
really well
and then like Brian Cox Tandy Newton
Zachary Quinto Peter Sarsgaard
Tommy Sadowski we're all sitting in the
front row and all started clapping and
it was like it was the happiest moment
of my career at that moment I was just I
felt my mom like was recording it from a
monitor it was really really happy she's
written by a wonderful wonderful writer
and playwright named Jon Robin baitz
Robbie baitz actually is one of the
reasons why I ended up doing Manchester
by the seas because him and Kenny came
up together in the same theatre company
I asked him to write me a letter of
recommendation
and he said we got off on a good foot
[Music]
Manchester by the sea the the movie
itself and the experience itself was the
farthest thing from depressing it was
like Kenny and Casey are all they did
was make jokes it's kind of amazing
because I think that is reflects pretty
well at least my part of the movie it's
people who are dealing with something
that's really tragic and traumatic but
there's always humor in it and the movie
does that really well I think it finds
humor in the awkwardness of tragedy and
like trauma but Kenny in case I found
myself just really like front with
front-row seats to like a comedy show
and when Matthew Broderick was on for a
few days they just laughed and laughed
and laughed I really felt like I had
been like called up I was like a
freshman and on JV baseball and I was I
called up to the varsity team and there
were these like older baseball players
who like I just like was so happy to be
on the same team of and but I like whose
are they gonna be my Guardians we filmed
that scene in like 4:00 in the morning
so I was like everything was a hit is
like really hazy I remember struggling
at first and it took it took it took a
little while for me to find my way into
that headspace and sat sadly it was one
of the scenes where it was like the
second I started to feel like I was
disappointing and they didn't make me
feel this way but the second I started
feeling like I was disappointing and
holding people behind that was like
where it all came from it wasn't one of
the scenes where it was like oh I got
this from the started out what that one
was tough they had liquids put all of my
heaviest emotional scenes three days in
a row and it was the third day so it
felt like it felt it felt a little dry
at first but it worked at my publicist
called me it's here and I was convinced
I wasn't gonna get nominated so I was
like I'm just gonna sleep in put my
phone in airplane mode and I woke up at
like 801 or something and was like yeah
you know I'll check like the second like
literally five seconds after I turned my
phone off airplane mode I get a call
from her she was like guess who just got
nominated for an Academy Award and I I
like sprung up ran downstairs my mom was
watching it on TV and my dad
ran out of the shower and it was really
I was like total cliche but like really
exciting like really really exciting I
don't know it's like really happy I was
happy
three billboards outside Epping Missouri
I was in the middle of my just finished
my first year at acting school and we
were studying this thing called the gist
er method which is a method that was
taught and founded by a man named Earl
gist er who taught at Yale MFA and I
remember going to first day of
rehearsals with Francis and being like
look I'm really lost I'm in school right
now we're working on the gift store
method I was like do you know what that
is and she was like yeah like when I was
in school we just called it Earl's class
because that was her teacher and I was
like she Wow
and she was like you want to do some of
it right yeah I found myself like going
from the gist er method class to like
working with Francis one of the greatest
actresses alive somebody who learned it
firsthand and was teaching it to me in a
way in a Martin McDonagh film it was
yeah it was it was sort of like it made
it clear to me I was like okay maybe I
don't need to maybe I don't need to go
back to school I've been a huge fan of
Sam's my whole life there's here's this
one I'm gonna shout out one of his most
underrated performances in a movie
called the winning season brilliant
brilliant performance and I remember
seeing that and being amazed by him when
I was like 12 years old
woody of course I grew up watching and
Peter Dinklage's actually lives down the
street from me and my dad taught him in
college my dad was his ink like theatre
teacher so there was some overlap there
I mean that those are some real iconic
dudes
lady bird that was fun that was like
Greta always had music playing she made
me a playlist she made everyone a
playlist Timmy had one sir she had one
beanie had one so we all had playlist
and and and from the moment I got on
that movie I knew we were making
something that felt timeless and it felt
like in the same it's a very different
movie but in the same way that like
people talk about Mean Girls or a movie
that survives it's it's it's time I felt
like we were making that every day felt
just like we'd get on set and it was
like oh my god that happened that
happened that happened and Greta was
like she would like I would be in the
middle of the scene and I could hear her
laughing off camera and there was an
immediacy to to the love I felt on that
set that I don't feel on most sets
typically it and it takes until it comes
out to know that we're making something
special but on that one we knew from the
first day Timmy Saoirse and beanie are
all like I mean Saoirse is already like
has been around for so long but Timmy
and beanie I felt like I was seeing two
great young actors like before their
moment it was even more special than
working with it with a veteran great
actor in a way it felt like we're I was
like a part of history getting to see
them at that moment boy erased boy
Reese's the first time I wasn't playing
like somebody's son or a supporting role
it was like it was like number one on
the call sheet I felt the weight of of
that story on my back in a way that was
both really motivating and really really
terrifying particularly because it's a
true story about a man I love and
respect him Garrett Connelly I wrote a
book called boy race that was the reason
why I wanted to do the movies because I
loved the book so much so it felt it
felt to me like it had all the makings
of something that could go really right
or terribly wrong which seemed to be the
perfect reason to do something and joel
of course is an amazing actor who i've
known for a long time and some
I really wanted to work with he directed
it and was acting in it so it really was
yeah I was have really new it was new a
new experience it's like a new I left
that movie being like okay I feel I felt
like I came of age in a way doing that
movie I wanted to play the character
because it seemed to me like he'd
overcome more in his life like over the
course of the span of the movie he'd
overcome more than I may may ever have
to have to face so I wanted to learn
from from from from his life and learn
from his mistakes and his triumphs and -
and learn from his mistakes and his
triumphs and and it was really like a
lot a lot a lot of fear so much fear
with of course that movie it's a
character lives in a lot of fear and but
but the moments of breakthrough were
really really transcendent and
triumphant for that reason mid-90s I
wanted to work with Jonah absolutely and
he wrote a script I really related to
and really wanted to be a part of and
felt to me like it it felt like another
world and that one of the things that
excites me most about film is that I get
to go in two distinct worlds and and
have these little adventures and this
and you watch the trailer for this movie
and it is a distinct world
[Music]
it's the mid-nineties I wear like the
dopest 90s clothing and that maybe the
baggiest pants fat farm pants and really
baggy jerseys and they got to hoop
earrings and dyed hair and timberlands
and I just walk around LA like in my
uniform my costume for a few like the
two weeks leading up to it and people
treated me so differently I'm a ride go
to like get food and people like you see
the game last night
I'd be like nah but I was like nobody's
ever said that to me in my entire life
like you catch the game was like I was
like what do people see right now when
they see me and I like registered a lot
of like fear in people's eyes like I
think there was something intimidating I
about me maybe I just I felt like I was
in really great hands with Jonah and he
knew what he was doing and it felt like
a story that really mattered to him so
that was another one that was like every
day on set it was like okay we're making
a movie right now huh
like in the similar way to Lady Bird
with Greta it was like okay I can't wait
to be of service to Him and and and
hopefully become a part of his life
because of it funny boy
this is the iconic character right here
this is the iconic case I mean nobody
more iconic and interesting than Shia
LaBeouf and in my opinion he wrote a
movie it's very much based on his
relationship with his father and the
second I saw his name attached I was
like okay like I'm reading this tonight
and it blew me away it felt more
specific and personal and intimate than
any script I've ever read which most a
lot of scripts can feel very formulaic
and and and sterile feel like okay now
is like when the plot moves forward but
this was like this was like we it was
weird and interesting and crazy and
politically like incorrect in a way that
it felt like it was depicting people
like in in in in this part of LA in the
90s - in the 2000s and I got to play
somebody base take as much inspiration
or as little inspiration from who I
believe to be one of the most
interesting people alive and do it
across from him and have him as a
resource whenever I needed he's the
hardest-working actor I've ever worked
with which made me want to step my game
up mmm and and I ended up going out to
LA like two months in advance because I
was like this dude's been prepping this
role his whole life so if I don't at
least give myself two months then I'm
gonna look like an idiot next so I
worked really hard and and I hope it
works Ben is back this this one comes
out in December and I never thought I'd
ever want to work with my dad after how
terrible he treated me during dan in
real life coming out no um I just put
the thought of it always seemed really
uncomfortable for me and felt like it
would make me feel self-conscious I did
an audition for this one so he didn't
make me read in the living room but I
read the script and it was one of the
best parts I'd ever read for somebody my
age felt different from anything I'd
ever played and it was right after boy
erased felt like a total 180
Julia's like she's a mom first that's
and she had me and my dad off to her
place and in California for a week and
he's clear to me that that she the love
she has for her kids is the strongest
thing in her life by far so to play her
son and to deal with that energy is
really really special because I was her
universe I was our whole world her whole
universe and it's it's nice to act
across somebody who really cares about
you and and she's so good to like so
talented all the things that I was
worried about in terms of being directed
by my dad ended up playing more into my
favor it's kind of like when I was doing
boy erase and I would I would feel lost
I would call my dad and be like I need
help and on this one he would he was my
director so I I had access to the man
who could put me at ease and also could
could talk to me about things from my
own life that would set me off emotion
in a way that he could support me in a
way that not not not most directors can
[Music]